Hello and welcome, everyone. It's July
15, 2023. We're here
in active inference model stream number
9.1 with Aspen Paul. Today we're going
to have a presentation and a discussion
on efficient computation in active
inference. So if you're watching along
live, please feel free to add comments
or questions in the chat. Otherwise,
Aswin, thanks so much for joining today.
Really looking forward to your talk.
Thank you, Daniel. Thank you so much.
So, as mentioned today, I'm here to talk
about efficient computation and active
inference. And yeah, let's get started.
So we are all familiar with this idea of
the free energy principle, which is also
known as active inference, right? So the
central concept is that an agent
minimizes entropy of its observation to
maintain homeostasis or survive in its
environment. And here the entropy is
defined in the information theoretic
sense, right? So if an observation is
highly probabilistic, that is less
entropic or less surprising because it
was high probability and we were
expecting it,
that's the idea, then that's the base
that we build this framework of active
inference on. And this idea of Marco
blanket, it gives us a systematic way of
surprising or systematic way of
separating an agent from its environment
and model purposeful behavior. Right?
So let's focus on this idea of
minimizing entropy. So how does an agent
minimize entropy or know which
observation is highly probabilistic and
vice versa? So that is by maintaining a
generative model. And the generative
model is basically a toy model of the
environment which the agent builds in
its brain and that is built
using only the observation that it gets
from the environment. So it has no
access to the real states or the hidden
states of the environment. It's building
the toy model. And given this toy model,
it has scope or ability to compute
the probability of an observation and
hence try to minimize the entropy.
Right? So that's the idea.
But it has a problem of cursive
dimensionality. Like, given a generative
model, it may not be possible always to
calculate or marginalize the probability
of observations out of it because the
state space can quickly become
intractable. But the idea is that you
define an upper bound on the surprise
using Jensen's inequality. And you may
also define a new term called Q,
which is the hidden belief or the belief
about the hidden states. And this Q is
going to be the focus of decision
making, right? So if you have a noisy
queue and you have no idea what's in the
environment, then you can't make or hope
to make decisions to control that
environment. And it is this belief about
the hidden states that you use and that
becomes useful to take decisions. And
this whole quantity is of course called
the free energy. And the variational
free energy F can be interpreted in
multiple ways. So the first or the most
common is the machine learning way of
how it is trying to minimize
the complexity of the model at the same
time trying to maximize the accuracy of
it. So that's the machine learning
interpretation of minimizing various
free energy. You may also try to
interpret free energy in the physics
term where you at the same time try to
minimize the energy of your model, but
at the same time trying to maximize the
entropy. But the focus of today or
decision making is always on this belief
that you have after you do the
perception in active inference. So how
do you do vanilla decision making? Or
what is the most discussed idea of
decision making in classical active
inference? So, if you are in an
environment and if you're an agent who's
trying to make decisions, then you have
a space of available actions, right? So
in this toy model, you have three
available actions run, jump or stay.
And given these actions, you can hope
to define a policy pi, small pi, which
is a sequence of actions in time and
capital T is the time horizon of
planning. Or that's the length of your
policy. And you have a policy space with
many such policies, small pi. So given
this bigger small C space, you can
attempt to evaluate the expected free
energy based on the beliefs that you
accumulated. So here you are not
minimizing anything. You already have a
belief from variation free energy and
you are just calculating or evaluating
the expected free energy corresponding
to many small policies that you can
define. And after you evaluate it for
all policies, then you know which is the
optimal policy to take. And that's the
classical active inference idea of
decision making, right? And this
expected free energy is really useful in
the sense that it is goal directed. So
the risk term is goal directed and then
you have this expected ambiguity term
that forces you to explore as well. But
there is a problem that this policy
space can quickly turn interactable and
that has always stayed as a bottleneck
in scaling active inference to commonly
seen environments. But let's see how it
becomes quickly intractable. So how many
policies can be defined, say, for a time
horizon of 15, right? So if you are
playing, say, supermago, you might want
to plan at least say, ten times steps
ahead. So the first policy could be
the same action run, stacked for
15 timesteps and you can basically
define several combinations of such
actions. And the policy space is simply
intractable. It becomes too huge for
you to evaluate the expected free energy
for all such policies. And in a
stochastic problem setting where the
environment itself is noisy, you don't
really have a method to choose a subset
of this policy space and do classical
active inference. And this is clearly a
computational intractable problem. And
that's why in literature we always see
small grids or small environments when
you discuss decision making in active
inference. But recently, a new idea was
proposed, which is called the
sophisticated inference. And in
sophisticated inference, it is not
really the policy space. You are
actually real time trying to think
what to do. So if you have a belief,
then you are trying to evaluate the
actions based on that. So here we don't
have a sequence of policies or things
that becomes intractable. Here we are
doing basically tree search in the sense
that you are trying to evaluate expected
free energy of this
joint distribution of actions and
observations and to evaluate the
expected free energy at some time small
T, you will also need the expected free
energy at the next time step. And to
evaluate that, you will need the
expected free energy of time T plus two.
And this basically becomes a tree search
that rolls out in time and it's
a recursive relation. And here
it's fundamentally different from the
policy space that we saw in the last
slide, right? And is it computationally
better in the sense that if you have to
plan, say, ten times steps ahead?
Comprehensively? In classical active
inference, we saw that the policy
spaces, the cardinality of the action
space raised to t, so that is the
computational bottleneck. If you have to
consider all possibilities. But in
sophisticated inference, it's even
worse, because you are considering
combination of state and actions. So it
is computationally worse in fact. But a
solution was proposed in the
sophisticated inference paper that we
can do pruning of this research, that we
can avoid some states and actions when
you do this research and that becomes
computationally very tractable. So let's
see how pruning works in sophisticated
inference. So this grid was discussed in
the original sophisticated inference
paper and say, for this grid, given that
you have this kind of prior preference
distribution, so this white square,
which is the gold state, is the most
preferred state. And you have a
uniformly decreasing preference for
states that is far away from that goal
state, then basically if you observe
yourself at some observation at Time T,
then basically what you're doing is
you're considering the consequence of
available actions from that
observations. And basically you can use
the projection of your belief and set
a threshold for those beliefs to kind of
maybe ignore some actions and ignore
some observations. And what you will
find is that it's no longer a tree
search, it's a subset of tree search and
it's computationally way efficient than
doing the whole tree search, right? So
here you have avoided a lot of
combinations and this becomes a
computationally tractable problem. This
is because you have decided to avoid
some actions and observations. So you
are essentially compromising on that
possibilities which might give you a
higher reward or which might be more
optimal than the consequence of this
partial research. But this works. So
this simulation was presented in the
paper and it works. The agent kind of
learns to do what needs to be done
if it plans in this forward direction of
planning in a pruned way.
And basically you can computationally
show that even for a small search
threshold, you can drastically decrease
the computational complexity. So if you
decide to do the whole research with the
planning depth, the computational time
is exponential and quickly you can't do
much about it. But if you decide a
search threshold which is even very
small, you can see that this problem
becomes computationally attractable.
And this demo on sophisticated
inferences available in my version of
PMDP and it's going to be integrated to
the original PMDP soon.
But the key point is that the pruning of
the tree search requires us a well
informed prior preference like this in
the sense that here the agent is aware
of how desirable are neighboring states,
it not only knows about the final goal
state, it also knows about its
neighboring state. And given such a
prior preference, we can see that for a
planning depth of three, the agent is
getting stuck basically in this local
maxima of prior preference. But with
sufficient planning depth it is able
to overcome this barrier and reach the
goal state in in this great problem.
And the question is that what if the
agent only knows this final state? It
has no other knowledge about what to do.
And in this case, what does the agent
do? So this is the problem that we are
trying to address and in the absence of
a meaningful trip reference like this,
the agent has basically no way of
reaching the goal state other than by
random exploration. It has no way of
planning because it cannot do planning
eight times steps ahead, because it's
computationally intractable. If it
chooses to do the full tree search,
right?
For a grid like this, what do you do if
you get a sparse trip reference which is
not well informed and as highlighted
in the previous slide, your research is
now blind, you have no way of pruning
the tree search, and you have to do the
full tree search in this scenario.
So, as you might have thought, there are
two solutions to this. Either you have
to find out a way to do the full depth
planning with
this past prior preference or you have
to learn a meaningful prior preference
which will enable you to do this pruned
research. So we are going to discuss
these two solutions in this presentation
for a given scenario like this. So, the
first solution to do full research is
basically using dynamic programming.
And dynamic programming is a well known
idea in operation research and
industrial engineering and many branches
of engineering. And the basic idea is
that you solve the subparts of a bigger
problem first and then later try to
integrate the solutions of these sub
problems to do optimal decision making.
So in this scenario, imagine that you're
trying to plan for the last action. So
earlier we started from the first
action, we started from the present and
tried to predict what is happening in
the future. So your direction of
planning was basically forward in time.
But imagine that you are trying to plan
only for the last time step where you
are just near the goal state and right
going to that goal state. Right. So you
are trying to make a decision for that
last time step, which is capital T minus
one, and your projections to
the next time step or the last goal
state can be done
because you have access to this model of
the world using this transient dynamics
or the B matrix in active inference. So
for this single time step, which is a
sub problem, you are actually evaluating
a table of expected free energy that
tells you if you are in, say, this
observation, what is to be done, which
is for the last time step. And basically
you can do this in state space or
observation space. So this can be done
using the A matrix and B matrix
together, where you can do planning
either way. Right. So the question is
that if you know what to do in the
last time steps, that you might be
thinking, how do I know that I'm in the
last time step? It is all about
imagining.
Sorry, last thing we heard for a second
was it's all about imagining.
Yeah. So just pick up from there. It's
all about imagining. Okay, so there was
a connection issue. Yeah, just for a few
seconds. It's all good then now. Oh,
sorry about that. So what I'm trying
to say is that you are trying to imagine
what you will do if you are in time
capital T minus one, which is the last
time step for your planning horizon.
And if you are in that time step, what
do I do? So this table represents all
such scenarios that if I am, say, at
observation three, at time T
minus one, what do I do? And this
quantity here, I'm only considering the
risk term or the purposeful term, and
this term represents that policy. And
what if I do this backwards till time
T minus one? So if I know what to do at
time capital T minus one,
then this table can inform what to do at
capital T minus two. So rather than
planning forward in time, what I'm doing
is basically stacking many tables
together just by fixing a capital T of
planning. And given that I have all
such stacked tables, then basically what
I can do is use them to take decisions
forward in time. And what we have
observed is that this idea works, that I
can calculate the expected free energy
backwards step by step,
considering them as sub problems. And
the fundamental difference is that in
sophisticated inference to calculate the
expected free energy at time small T,
you don't know what is the expected free
energy at time T plus one. So this
becomes a research so that you have to
calculate this first and to calculate
for T plus one you need t plus two and
so on. But here because you're
calculating it backwards in time. You
already know what is the expected free
energy for T plus one. And it's
basically the same equation. It's just
that you're doing it backwards in time
and pictorially in sophisticated
inference. You are trying to do a tree
search. But in the dynamic programming
algorithm, you are doing your planning
backwards, using tables. And given your
planning horizon is sufficient enough
for a problem, what we have seen is that
the agent will be able to take optimal
actions forward in time. So in
the paper we are also proposing one
algorithm for sequential palm DPS using
this backward planning in time and we
were able to scale up simulations for
grid spaces which was previously
intractable without neural networks. So
that was the first solution. So the
second solution is that so in the first
solution it was fixed that you only get
a sparse prior preference, you don't get
any other information, you only get your
information about the final goal state
and all you get is the model of the
environment which you learn and you
basically have to take decisions. But
the second solution of course is that if
you're allowed, you can attempt to learn
a pride preference which is meaningful
like the one we saw in the previous
slides, which has the information about
the other states also. But how do you
learn it? Right? So there is a seminal
work from optimal control literature
that talks about efficient computation
of optimal actions and in that work
there is a quantity similar to our prior
preference which is called the
Desirability function. So for example,
in this grid world here darker colors
are more preferred. So if this crosses
your final gold state, what the agent in
this paper is trying to do or the said
learning method in this paper is trying
to do, is learn this Desirability
function as optimally as possible. And
what has been shown in this paper is
that if you try to learn the
Desirability function using a particular
learning rule, it is computationally far
more efficient than even Q learning
which is a well known reinforcement
learning algorithm. So Q learning is a
well known computationally optimal
algorithm but in this paper that
particular learning rule for learning
this kind of a Desirability function is
way faster and this approximate error
represents how different it is from the
optimal Desirability function. So this
Desirability function is nothing but our
prior preference and as mentioned
learning set is borders of magnitude
efficient than learning the Q function
in Q learning. So this is the particular
learning rule depending upon the reward
that it gets from the environment and in
this particular grid world environment
we are only giving it reward at the last
step which is similar to the sparse
parent preference, the agent basically
gets no reward until it reaches
that final goal state. And with this
learning rule which has a parameter ETA
that controls how fast or slow this
learning happens. So basically we tried
to study the effect of this
learning parameter ETA, but what we
observed is that it's very robust, it
can learn the prior preference reliably
even with variable values of this
learning parameter. And what we see is
that the agent is able to learn a
meaningful prior preference over time
very fast and using such a meaningful
prior preference, then the agent don't
have to plan a lot, it can manage
optimal behavior or purposeful behavior
with very low time horizons of planning.
And given these two solutions, we could
scale up active inference algorithm for
decision making and talking about the
computational efficiency, we saw that
the dynamic programming method could
plan 30 timesteps into the future with
only say a computational complexity of
thousand when compared to say ten to the
power 68 for sophisticated inference.
And the second method which learns the
prior preference which we call active
inference and it only needs to plan one
time step ahead, so it is way more
computationally efficient in that sense,
but it has to learn. So in the Dpsv
method we are not learning, we are using
the sparse sprite preference and doing
the whole depth of planning and in the
other method we are letting the agent
learn this prior preference but then we
can save planning a lot because it knows
a lot of what to do in time, right?
So graphically we can see that the
Dpfe method is really computationally
efficient and when plotted against time
in the AI t equal to one method, it is
basically computationally way cheaper.
So it scales very fascinatingly well
with higher and higher complexity
of the environment. So we tested these
methods in very huge state spaces
like say 900 states compared to state
spaces which has dimension of say five
or ten in the usually seen active
inference literature. So I want to
kind of emphasize that we are not using
any neural networks here, we are using
explainable active inference agents
doing all necessary matrix
multiplication so that we have access
and explainability to every
computation that is taking place in
these algorithms. And when tested on
these grids first, we validated this on
a smaller grid with hundred states. And
we observed is that when compared to
benchmark reinforcement learning
algorithms like Q learning and Dynaq,
dynaq is a model based reinforcement
learning algorithm. And we compared our
newly proposed agents, which is Dpfe and
AIF, and we saw really good performance
and AIF agent is slightly worse. And
that's because it's only planning one
time step ahead, right? But the Dpfe
agent who does full time planning, it's
performing as good as benchmark
reinforcement learning algorithms. And
we tested it with bigger and bigger
grids. And when we introduced
Stochasticity in the goal state, in the
sense that when the agent had to
navigate to Stochastic
goal state. So we changed the goal
states at every ten episodes. And what
we observed is that the Dynaq took more
time than our Dpfe agent to kind of
recover and do well. So Dpfe agent in
this Stochastic environment performed
really well, even better than the Dynaq
agent, and we could also see that the
AIF agent is recovering faster
but not as good as the other agents. So
basically that was the result in the
paper and the methods. So, yeah, thank
you for listening, and I'm open for
discussions.
All right. Awesome. Wow.
Very cool. Thank you.
Okay, well, just as we start the
discussion, if anyone wants to add
anything first, just how did you come to
work on this project? Were you studying
active inference and you came to this
question as being interesting, or were
you working on the planning and came to
active inference as a method?
Yeah, so little bit background about
myself. So I studied physics both in my
undergrad and postgrad, and towards the
end of my post graduation, I got
interested in things like game theory
and reinforcement learning, and I joined
for a joint PhD with Professor Adela
and Professor Manoj. And so Professor
Manoj is a control theory person, and
Adela is a neuroscientist. And in the
beginning of my PhD, I started reading
active inference literature, and I
wanted to implement that in problems.
And I was always fascinated with
explainable active inference about this
idea of expected free energy, trying to
minimize risk as well as expected
ambiguity. Just so not just making the
agents work, but also being able to tell
how they work is what fascinated me in
active inference. And initially, I tried
to implement them, and there is a
conference paper which we published in
which we compared it for a similar grid
world task. And then I faced this
problem of scaling active inference,
and then I started working on
sophisticated inference. Yeah, so
basically these methods came out of the
need that I wanted to scale the map up.
And I always had was skeptical in using
deep active inference because I
didn't want to use neural networks to do
planning, because deep reinforcement
learning in itself is a huge field. And
if you're about just scaling active
inference, then maybe just do deep
reinforcement learning. That's what I
thought. Yeah. So that's basically the
background, and that's how it came
about. All right, I'll go first to a
question in the live chat, and we'll
just probably discuss various aspects
because there was a lot in your
presentation. So ML. Don writes,
I wonder, when it comes to computing the
expected free energy over a time
horizon, what kind of mean field
approximation was used to factorize Q of
S? Sure.
So I assume that the question is about
the expected free energy in Dpfe, and to
calculate this, basically. So in
my simulations, I use belief propagation
for this belief cube and you
can also use variation message passing
or marginal message passing. That's not
a problem.
Once you have this belief queue,
what do you do? Right?
Yeah. So when I say
you imagine Q for a time,
then what I use mostly is one hot
vector. So to take decisions, you use
the belief that you get out of your
perception step in active inference.
But for imagining, these are hard tables
where they are one hot vector. So given,
say, in your generative model has ten
states. The queues that you use are
precise queues for planning. But for
decision making you use the imprecise
mean field approximation queue that you
get from the perception step. So I don't
know if that answers the question, but
maybe I also need to think about more
about the approximation that may be
there in steps. Cool.
Yeah, they can write more if they want.
Let's talk a little bit more generally
about preference learning. So in the
context of the active inference
generative model, we have a mediating
between observations and hidden states
and learning makes a lot of sense. It's
about learning the mapping between
observations and hidden states of the
world. And then we have B learning,
learning the consequences of action and
how things change through time. And
preference learning is learning on C.
And you've highlighted that this is a
very interesting
variable to learn. And I'm curious,
how do we learn to learn the right
thing? How do we know that we're
learning in adaptive preference? And
then how does that preference learning
reduce cognitive overhead or
computational complexity? Yeah,
great. So if you are
trying to learn a prior preference,
then that assumes that there is
something to chase or there is something
to maximize, like a reward. So in
a reinforcement learning setting, there
is clear reward that's coming from the
environment that you're trying to
maximize. And say for this grid, you get
that reward only in the last step.
That's what makes this problem hard. So
if you are getting rewards at every time
step, then basically you know what to do
that I just have to pursue that reward
at every time step. Right? But here you
might have to take say, 15 time steps
ahead to get that one reward and that
basically is hard to do. So here,
because I'm trying to learn a prior
preference, there should be a reward
structure that exists in the
environment. If the environment doesn't
care about what I do or if I can't
define what is good or bad, then there
is no meaning in learning the prior
preference. Right? So here the reward is
what controls the learning of this prior
preference. And the good thing is that
even if only I get the reward at the
last time step, I have my B matrix
and I have experience of transitioning
from different states, which I reached
this final goal state. And this
algorithm that we are using, or the
learning rule that we are using, is
precisely learning a similar thing in
optimal control. That paper I introduced
which is called the desirability
function. And given that you have this
desirability function so imagine that
maybe I'm starting from this state,
then I just have to look at my nearest
neighbors to take a decision. If the
state at state below the state is
more preferred, then I only have to plan
one times ahead and that's the optimal
decision I have to take. So learning
this prior preference reduces the
cognitive load in the sense that I'm
only now looking at nearest neighbors,
I don't have to plan all the way up to
this final goal state. And I will learn
this as efficiently as possible because
one, it is a guaranteed algorithm, we
tested its robustness and it is also
informed by the reward that I get from
the environment. If there is
some way to kind of define what is
preferred then you are guaranteed to
learn a pride preference that's
meaningful by this algorithm.
So if only nearest neighbors and
one time step inference is being used,
then what prevents this kind of
preference learning agent from being
stuck in a local optima?
Yeah, so there won't be local optimas
here. That's the point.
Why would there be a local optima if I
am learning it using rewards?
Yeah. So if there is local optima, then
it will be getting stuck in the local
optima. But there won't be one if you're
learning us this way because you're
learning it from your own experience and
how you got the reward at time sometime.
And what we observed is that it's very
gradual and there is no glitches or
local optimus when you learn such a
practical. So it's kind of backfilling
a preference so that
there can be a smooth path to the
distal goal. Yes. So the animation
kind of makes it look like a backfilling
but you're actually learning it from
your experience forward in time.
Right. So I observed a reward when I
transition from this state to this
state. So this must be good. Then in the
next time step I say, okay, this state
is responsible for taking me there. So
this might be good also, but not as good
as the other one. So it looks like it's
learning backwards, but it's actually
learning from the real t to T plus one
experience.
Okay. So in that way you
can't have local maximas because this
is the learning rule that does that. I
don't know how to answer it more
systematically. Yeah.
What real world situations or what
real life situations do you kind of see
this kind of preference learning
happening in?
Yeah, great question. So,
so there is one paper that came out from
our lab where neurons are laying
learning the game of poem.
So it's a paper is called Dish Brain and
the device is called Dish. Brain. And
what they have accomplished is that they
managed to culture neurons on a silicon
chip and they gave it
a good feedback signal when it
successfully tackled the ball or played
the game well and gave it a shock when
it made mistakes. And what we saw is
that in the paper, what we see is that
it learns to play the game over time.
Right. And in such a scenario, imagine
that if I encounter, say, a positive
thing in the world, then I might
associate what is good with the
states I observed in the past and so on.
Right. So I learned step by step
what is good or bad, and that's a
reasonable hypothesis to make. So if
I want to say, get fitter, then I
might associate going to gym as
a good thing. Then I might also
associate walking to the gym as a good
thing. Then I might associate, say,
wearing my shoes as a good thing. So
learning prior preference that way makes
sense, I would say. But yeah, this is a
computational solution to the problem
of cursive dimensionality. But testing
this on the real world is definitely
what we should do. And yeah, I also look
forward to doing that.
Okay, let me try to run a real world
situation by you and see if this
connects. So we're
rewarded by turning in an essay that
gets a high grade. And so there's many
steps between starting the idea of the
essay and seeing that preferred sparse
outcome, which is the grade,
and we do all kinds of things, and then
we learn, okay, well, this one where I
did get a good grade, it was well
formatted. And then now
you sort of expand the umbrella of your
preference out, and then you go, well,
what brought me to getting it well
formatted? Well, I did it on time. And
then you kind of work all the way to the
ideation phase so that in the future
you can do one step inference exactly.
And just take it step by step as a
skill, instead of needing to do a 15
time step inference over all the
possible tree structures. So you've kind
of used your embodied learnings
to simplify the structure of the
problem. Exactly, yeah.
And can we look at the computational
complexities again of all them?
So here, CIF stands for the classical
active inference. And to do the full
horizon of planning, it's around ten to
the Power 18. So this is for this
particular grid example with hundred
states and four available actions.
So this is for a special case, and I
just wanted to put numbers to put things
in perspective. So for this particular
example, if you are trying to do it with
the policy space thing, you will have to
do ten to the Power 18 computations for
one step of planning or in one instance,
in sophisticated inference, it's even
worse because the state space also
matters. And that won't work.
So this third line was supposed to kind
of show that even for a time horizon
of two, it's really hard to do
sophisticated inference if you have to
do the full planning. But with dynamic
programming, when you're planning
backwards, you can attempt to do the
full horizon of planning and that's only
1000 computations. But with learning
prior preference, it's even low when you
do it just one time step ahead.
Wow, this is quite stark.
And in the branching time active
inference work. In a previous model
stream, we also saw some computational
complexity estimates. But I think these
are really clear. First thing it made
me think of is no one said
sophistication was cheap.
I mean, it's astronomical how costly it
is for maybe even only at two
or three or four or five potentially
starting to get up to so it's increasing
the complexity of planning radically.
So it's very interesting pedagogically
as we think about like, as we imagine
active inference, intelligence
architectures, but this
makes it pretty clear that it's not
something that you can just enumerate
over. And so I think it's very creative
and important what you've done by
connecting this to principled
methods of computational complexity
reduction rather than potentially
effective but ad hoc methods of
complexity reduction, like neural
networks, which might work when they
work, but then once those start to get
bloated, now you have no principles and
no efficacy. Exactly, yeah. And
sophisticated inference, I must note,
that has its own benefits when compared
to dynamic programming, in the sense
that when you're planning forward, you
are taking into consideration all the
possibilities. Right. But when you're
planning backwards, say, for example,
like queue based exploration,
like if you have to go somewhere, get a
queue and then navigate to the goal
state, then planning backwards might not
work. So this was one feedback I got
when I discussed the work with some
people. So that's a thing to note
about dynamic programming. But the other
place where you learn prior preference,
I believe it's not a problem, but yeah,
dynamic programming is computationally
cheap, but it also come with its own
limitations, I must note. There,
just to restate, that in dynamic
programming, with a bellman optimality,
we're solving backwards. And so it's
kind of like the checkmate is what we
want and so now we're working backwards
to the present, but we end up not
exploring counterfactual endpoints.
We don't work back to the present to
endpoints that we're not interested in.
Exactly. So that's why it's so ruthless.
But on the other hand, it's a much more
constrained search.
Yes. So what I'm thinking about
these cases that we should also consider
combinations of these two where I can
afford to kind of ignore such
counterfactual things. There I can do
dynamic programming and maybe I can do
as two steps of planning. So if
it's a queue based exploration, say
reaching Q is one task and
from Q to the reward is the other task.
So I can separate these two and use
dynamic programming for them and that's
computationally cheaper, but also kind
of preserves this idea of having to do
it. Yeah, but these are all future
things I am thinking about. Cool. I'll
ask another question from the chat Alex
wrote. Do you have ideas or
developments on nested models where
different scales could have different
one time step ahead and speed of
execution? So how does this model play
out in nested models? And how do
we think about this forwards and
backwards in time in the speed of
execution and nested models? Okay,
so I might need a little more context
here. Like when you say nested models,
do you mean hierarchical models? Yeah.
So maybe something like
there is an observation. I get on a fast
pace and I do some inference on
that, but then I use this inference to
kind of do and
basically this inference becomes the
observation for the next state. That's
what nested models mean, right? Yes.
So I might have to actually think about
that in terms of a task and then think
about it. But honestly, I haven't
thought how this might work in that
context, but say, for a task.
So in terms of navigation, if you think
about it, you can think about,
say, rooms environment. So that's
one of the examples I can think about
where you can apply this. So imagine
maybe you have a collection of rooms and
as an agent, you have to first figure
out which room to go and then you have
to navigate inside that room. And
basically you can do inference in two
stages or decision making in two stages.
And you will have to separate your
decisions in those stages inside the
room. You can do, say, dynamic
programming to navigate your optimal
path, but you will always have to kind
of have two stages of decision making
and maybe different methods work better
at different stages. But this would be
better, this discussion would be better
to better in
a well thought out task, I would say.
I don't have an answer that might be
fitting for everything. But yeah,
we've seen almost exactly that kind of
hierarchical simultaneous localization
and mapping slam in a robotics case.
There have been active inference models
on that. Would it be possible to
sort of do one
of these methods at one level of the
nested model and then have another
computational method applied to another?
Or if you wanted the advantages of one
in one place, can you mix and match with
these different methods even within one
simulation? Yeah,
I definitely think that's possible,
but we'll have to maybe try.
So all my methods are one stage. It's
not a hierarchical model, but I
strongly believe that it would also work
in an estate model where you can have
two methods of decision making working
together in, say, for a room example. I
just mentioned. Cool. Could you go to
the slide on Z learning?
Yeah.
Cool. Yeah. So I noticed here and in the
great paper that you had several totorov
citations. Yes. And this introduction
of the Z learning is a novelty with
respect to the active inference field.
So could you explain a little more what
is the Z and what is it that
enables such a rapid improvement
in the Z with respect to the Q? Yeah.
Okay. So to give some context about
this paper,
it talks about a linear method of
decision making in a particular class of
MDP. So given that you are having a
markout decision process where your
actions can be based on states and not
actions. So when you think about actions
in a, say in, for example, a grid world
task, you think about left right and
north south right? So if I take a north,
then that has a consequence on state
space. But in this paper, they're
introducing a class of MDP where
decision is itself in terms of states.
So if I am, say, in state s one, my
decision will be depending upon the
other states. So my decision will be
based on the other states I want to be
in the next time step. So it's
a redefinition of decision making in
terms of the state space rather than
decisions being something else like left
right and down up. So given that such
an MDP exists where I can take decisions
in terms of states,
they have showed that computationally
you can take decisions in linear
complexity, however big the problem is.
So for that to enable decision making in
terms of states, you should have a sense
of what is good and bad for the states.
So in this grid word example, you have
a desirability function which is C. So C
is the desirability function which talks
about how desirable is this tip? And if
I have a C function, then what they have
showed is that I can take decisions
with linear computational complexity for
this particular class of MDP. So if my
MDP allows me to take decisions in terms
of states, it's only linear
complexity for that thing. So this
graph is basically comparing how you can
learn desirability better or
faster, right? So Q learning, if you're
familiar with Q learning, it's basically
a table based method where you have
desirability of actions given a state.
So given a state, you know what to do.
That's basically the Q matrix. But in
terms of C or the C
learning method, it's only about states.
You're only learning how desirable a
state is. There is no concept of action
states. And this is exactly what our
prior preference is in active inference,
where it is a distribution that
quantifies how desirable or non
desirable states are.
So given that they have shown
that you can learn the C matrix faster
and that's optimal and it's way faster
than even Q learning, then I thought,
okay, why not try to learn C the same
way as C is learned in this paper and
using this. So there is a similar
learning rule for learning C, which is
called set learning in that paper. And
when I attempted to learn C, what I've
seen is that it learns really fast a
useful prior preference that lets me
take decisions or let the active
inference agent take decisions only by
say, one time step of planning.
So basically that's a story.
This idea of C being easily learnable is
in that paper, the Tarot paper.
Okay, let me try to restate that since I
think it's a very interesting
augmentation of active inference. So
we're going to be learning C for all
the reasons we discussed earlier.
We're going to learn C analogously
to how Todorov presented Z learning.
And in the Z learning,
instead of learning, for example,
updated posterior probabilities on
actions and then using actions to
navigate amongst states that emit
observations, we're going to
kind of bake the action into
the states. So that really we're
learning transitions amongst states
directly.
And to connect this to the free energy
principle and how it is playing out with
active inference here,
C is not just our desirability function,
that's one way of thinking about it.
That's why we call it preference. But
also C is our expectation. And so
that is what allows us to, on one hand
use the language familiar to reward and
preference learning. Like the agent is
ending up where it likes to be, but also
the expectation based definition
of C. These are the same thing allows us
to talk about that as a path of least
action or as the most likely outcome
or the least surprising outcome. And
because we've defined it what we want
as the least surprising outcome, then we
can use variational free energy to bound
surprise, whereas you can't use simply a
variational method to bound or even
necessarily approximate reward itself.
But if you say I prefer what
I expect and what I expect reduces
my surprise and I'm going to bounce
surprise, then you get both
that sort of behavioral reward seeking
couched in a surprise bounding
surprise minimizing physics framework.
Yeah, that's a beautiful way of saying
it. Yeah. Thank you.
Well, what are your next exciting
steps or directions or what ways do you
want to take this work? Yeah, great. So
if you are talking about only this work,
what I want to do next is think
about queue based exploration tasks.
First of all, address the limitations of
dynamic programming. So if you
have, say, a queue to explore in this
grid first and that's more optimal, I
want to see how the expected ambiguity
term in the expected free energy is
useful and should be made use in the
dynamic programming strictly in that
sense. But more generally,
I'm also looking at other ways of making
decisions in active instance. Like there
are works from professor Isamura
from CBS Reckon, he talks about
how neural networks are doing active
inference and basically decision making
there is really more efficient
in the sense that it's like Q learning.
So there he's making clever use of the
variation free energy to learn good
state action mappings and it's a very
drastic change to what we are used to
in terms of expected free energy. So
there is no concept of expected free
energy in that work. It's all
about learning what is good and bad
directly from variation of free energy.
So I find that also fascinating. I want
to kind of explore that more and see how
decision making in this way is
better or worse or should be thought
about. Should we even reconsider ways of
decision making? Because active
inference only talks about variation of
free energy and that's the central
tenet. Everything else is your
interpretation of that. Right,
that's another direction I want to work.
Interesting way to say it. Definitely
the variational free energy, which is
a functional of our variational
distribution Q and the data y,
the variational free energy is kind of
like the real time homeostasis,
like how are things making sense given
what I believe and the incoming data.
And then to extend that kind of a sense
making framework into decision making,
we've seen a lot of different methods.
Expected free energy is a common
one, but for example, there's been free
energy of the expected future and
there's other constructions that
have different methods.
And then you pointed also to Professor
Samura's work with the sort of
relationship between the variational
free energy on the base graph and the
loss function in a neural network and
all those relationships. That's very
exciting work too,
I guess kind of in closing, just as a
last question or thought, you're coming
close to the end of your PhD. So just
in the time that you've been a PhD
student, how have you seen active
inference develop or what
feels different to you today near the
end than when you were fresh
eyed and excited several years ago?
Yeah, that's a really great question and
I am also very excited of how the field
has evolved. And frankly, I started from
this reinforcement learning background
and the physics background, and when I
started reading, it was only, say, one
or two papers and I did not quite
understand much of it. It was only when
I started implementing it using Carl's
MATLAB scripts, I kind of understood,
okay, this makes sense and I like it.
But within, say, one or two years, I saw
a lot of papers coming in from different
directions and people also starting to
use neural networks and all this scaling
up came. And at some point I also
questioned the need of active inference
because if you have deep reinforcement
learning, which can do many things, and
why deep active inference? And that's
the reason why I did not get into that.
But I still find it fascinating. I want
to kind of understand deep, active
inference more than what I know now,
but I've seen the field growing, like
anything in two or three years, and many
cohorts of people starting to work. And
in no time, it was a seriously taken
field other than a field with,
say, two papers with nobody actually
knowing what it is. So it's really
exciting. Yeah. So I really look forward
how the field evolves in time and also
what I can do after my PhD and so
on. Cool. Forward in time,
backward in time, what we prefer, what
we expect. Yes.
Any other comments or anything else you
want to add? Yeah, so please let me
know what you think about the paper and
what you think about these ideas. Feel
free to let me know. I really look
forward to the feedback and yeah.
Thanks so much for this opportunity,
Daniel, and thank you for your time. It
was amazing. I hope people check out the
paper and get in touch and replicate the
code and take it their own direction.
Thank you. See you next time. See you
next time. Thank you so much. Bye. Have
a good day.